- Hi, everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the
Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism.
It's my great pleasure to
welcome you this afternoon
to the second in our special
Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series,
devoted to exploring the connections,
but also the divergences,
between antisemitism
and other forms of racism and prejudice.
I'm really happy to
introduce today's speaker,
Cathy Park Hong.
She holds degrees from Oberlin
and the University of Iowa,
and is currently professor
of creative writing
at Rutgers Newark.
Considered one of America's
most innovative poets,
she's the author of three
collections of poetry,
including "Dance, Dance, Revolution",
which was chosen by Adrienne Rich
for the Barnard Women Poet's Prize.
Among her many other honors,
I'll mention just the
Guggenheim Fellowship,
the National Endowment
for the Arts Fellowship,
and Yale's own Windham Campbell Prize.
Many of you, no doubt,
remember her electrifying
lectures on campus,
when she received that prize, in 2018.
Today though, we're here to talk about
Cathy Park Hong's most recent
book of creative nonfiction,
"Minor Feelings: an
Asian-American-Reckoning."
This book was released last February
and has received what can only be called
a passionate response in the press.
Writing in the New Yorker,
the critic Jia Tolentino said,
"Cathy Park Hong's book of essays
bled a dormant discomfort
out of me with surgical precision."
Claudia Rankin said,
"To read this book is
to become more human."
So, the plan for today,
is that I'm gonna engage
Cathy in discussion
for about a half an hour
and then I'll ask her
questions from the audience.
So please submit your
questions to me at any time,
during the discussion,
using the Q and A function
at the bottom of your Zoom screen.
The chat function is disabled
and audience members will
remain otherwise muted.
So now, please join me in
welcoming Cathy Park Hong.
Hi, Cathy.
Unmute yourself.
- [Cathy] Oh, okay.
- Great, okay.
Well, welcome.
So let me just say that,
I just thought this book
was totally amazing.
It's so smart, so brave
and I think it's really an important book,
especially right now,
as we engage in this kind of
collective conversation
about racism in the U.S.
So, thank you so much for being here.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you for inviting me
and I'm really happy to be present
and talk to everyone at Yale here.
- Terrific, okay well let's dive in.
So, my first question,
you begin with an excruciating,
but also hilarious story
of getting rejected by
and then kind of stalking
a Korean therapist,
when you were depressed.
So, you were sure that she would
understand all your issues,
because she was Korean,
and then you couldn't believe it,
when she didn't wanna
take you on as a client,
maybe because of the dozens of voicemails
that you left on her machine.
So the story immediately made me think
I was gonna love the book,
but I'm curious, if you
could say a little bit more
about why you chose to put this kind of
painful anecdote, right at the beginning.
- Probably because it was
an excruciating experience.
It's both kind of absurd
and rather abject.
I think really, I wanted to,
maybe I started with that anecdote,
because I also wanted
to disarm the reader.
So I think perhaps in maybe
a more conventional kind
of memoir, nonfiction book,
there's an encounter with the therapist
and especially if it's a
therapist of the same culture,
the same cultural background,
there is a kind of kinship that's kindled
and then the retelling and
the talking cure begins.
Instead, in my anecdote,
the therapist just slams
the door in my face,
where I was expecting this
kind of shared kinship.
There was a Korean word for it,
(speaking in Korean)
instead, she just flat out rejects me.
Which I was so insulted
and hurt by at the time.
But in retrospect, I also
find it kind of funny.
So, it kind of actually,
kind of gave me a bit of
a glee to begin with that,
to disarm the reader on
what this book was gonna be.
Also, to show that the persona,
it's also I would say
that myself in the book
is kind of persona,
is not exactly gonna be
this nice, neutral person.
But besides from disarming the reader,
I think I also wanted to,
I mean so much of the book
is about my interiority
and being public about my interiority.
There is a lot of passages
about mental health
and that which is still very taboo
among many Asian-Americans.
So it seemed appropriate
to begin with my attempt,
at least, to find a therapist
and also in the book,
I talk about how finding
a Korean therapist,
I wanted to find a
Korean-American therapist,
because I didn't have to
explain myself as much.
The therapist would just look at me
and know what I was talking about.
Then I talk about how I
had to explain myself.
This was sort of my own
kind of reckoning was,
which I resisted as a poet.
it was to kind of explain myself to myself
and explain myself to people,
to others in my community, or my family,
my friends and so to speak.
For so long, I also resisted
writing this kind of book,
the kind of book about
Asian-American identity.
I was like, "Well okay,
if I'm gonna really do it,
I'm gonna really dive into
it and just explain myself,
but not to a white audience.
Explain myself to more to people who share
what I've been through."
More that, of course it's for everyone.
But I think those were the
people I had in mind at first.
- Right and I would note that
it was actually a Jewish therapist
who actually you wound up (laughs)
seeing.
- I know, I know.
Our friend, we have a mutual friend Gita
and she read an early draft of the book.
Then when she saw it (laughs),
when I said, "I happened to
find a Jewish therapist."
She found that to be
the funniest (laughs).
She found that to be hilarious.
She's still my therapist,
she's amazing (laughs).
(laughing)
- Well, this actually leads
me to my next question,
which is that I feel like
there are many overlaps between
the Korean, or the
Asian-American experience
and the Jewish American experience,
that I wasn't even aware
of, until I read your book.
But one of the big ones I think,
is this idea of self-hatred.
You describe, there's
a very funny passage,
you describe wondering,
"Who let in all the Asians?"
When you find yourself in
a room with other Asians.
It of course made me think of
Groucho Marx's famous line
about not wanting to join a club
that would have him as a member.
So I'm wondering if you could just say
a little bit more about self-hatred
and about how internalized
prejudice manifests itself,
for you, or for minorities, in general.
- I mean, I will say that,
writing this book,
there is like a rich
tradition of Jewish writers
and also Black writers who
write about their self-hatred
in ways that are both full of rage,
but also funny and neurotic.
So those are definitely the kind of models
that I was like thinking
about in writing about this.
But I think like, yeah, no.
I mean, it's hard 'cause
you grow up with it.
I think like what what's very canny about
living in a white dominant society,
or white supremacist society,
is that world I would say,
is that it creates divisions,
is the divisions that it creates.
It's not between races,
between ethnic groups within races
and also divisions within
people in ethnic groups,
within your family and
also within yourself.
Because, to form any kind of coalition,
would be a threat to those who hold power.
That's probably something that
we're all kind of abstractly aware of,
but it's really insidious when it works,
when it starts when you're very young
and then like it's drilled into you
and it's hard to kind of separate yourself
from that sensibility.
Where I grew up in LA and my family spent
a lot of time in Korea Town.
It's not like I grew up in
like Wichita or anything.
But I went to a high
school that was very white
and I also lived in a
neighborhood later on,
that was also quite white.
Or even like I remember
visiting Orange County,
which has changed a
lot, since I was a kid.
But back then, it was super racist.
I mean, really just
blatantly, blatantly racist.
I'd be hanging out with my cousins
and the white kids would say,
"Oh look, there's a Korean parade."
So from the early on,
I knew that being among other
Koreans or other Asians,
was to invite ridicule,
because we were making
ourselves conspicuous.
We were just there.
It was the same for any
other marginalized group.
If you're thinking about
Orange County again,
back then, Mexican
Americans were considered
dirty Mexicans, if they went
to beaches or certain pools,
because they were kind
of infecting the waters,
and of course, Black Americans are,
if there too many of them,
then they're considered intimidating,
threatening and so forth.
But I think for Asians,
it was more ridicule.
You still see that,
if you see like groups of Asian tourists.
There's this sort of, people tend to
mock Asians and so forth.
Even at the high school,
the Asians were very self-aware of that.
There was a group where,
they called themselves,
"The Asian Invasion."
I think there's, which is like, yes,
it was sort of making fun of it
and also maybe like just taking it
and sort of reversing it and be like,
"Yes, we're the invasion, so what?
what are you gonna do about it?"
But I think that Asian Invasion,
is with that nice little rhyme,
is really just, that kind
of encapsulates the threat
that we pose as a collective
and that we will invade institutions,
or positions of power,
or I guess like most,
the examples that we
find most often in media,
is our schools, right?
There's this very kind of
corporatized, institutionalized
notion of diversity,
where it's fine, as long as the majority
is still pretty white.
Then you have samplings
from other racial groups.
But if you have too many black people,
too many Latinex people, too many Asians,
then we're a threat.
So that's what was happening
with say, Harvard, right?
Because and there was
that discrimination case,
because there were too many Asians
and of course there's
a Jewish corollary too.
- I was just, yeah, listening to you.
I mean that, Jews had
faced a very similar thing.
Starting in the 1920s,
that's when they started having quotas,
because all of a sudden there were
so many Jewish students who
started to do well on the tests.
In fact, it was supposedly
that's when they started to
create the holistic kind
of approach to admissions
and start grading on character
and all these things as
a way to exclude Jews
and that's being deployed often again.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
It's like the kind of
well-rounded individual
and like what's the subtext of that,
is that like Asian-Americans are robotic.
Only interested in math and so forth.
So I think it's kind
of colonized condition,
where you just sort of,
where we believe it too.
Where if you're with other
people who look like you,
you know you lose your
personhood, your subjectivity.
So it's better to be separate,
that you don't do that,
rather than forming, having solidarity
and feeling proud that
you're with other people,
who share your culture.
So yeah, it's a big issue.
- A kind of related point is this,
and another thing that I think links
the kind of Jewish American experience
and Asian-American experience,
is the model minority myth.
So this idea which you brilliantly
deconstruct in the book
that Asians are expected not to complain,
because some of them
are doing economically
pretty well or are even next
in line to become white,
as someone says to you, in the book.
So I'm wondering if you
could say a little bit more
about that model minority myth
and who's interests it serves
and how it affects members
of the minority group.
- Oh, I mean, I think it ultimately
serves white Americans, white people.
Or maybe not white people,
but more just sort of the
kind of racial hierarchy,
that we live in currently.
But I'm not gonna lie,
it also benefits Asians
too, in certain ways.
But I mean, I go into it in the book
and I think anyone who's even just
have the most superficial understanding of
Asian-American history know that
Asians were used as a counter example
to the Civil Rights Movement,
that we weren't uppity and that we weren't
gonna ask for a government handout,
so we work hard.
It's carried on in the '80s and '90s,
there's like Reagan's notion of
the welfare queen and the welfare mother.
Asian-Americans were those who, again,
just worked hard and worked diligently
and through grit,
got their kids into universities
and lived the American dream.
As I said in the book,
a lot of that's also fallacious,
because Asians who ended
up coming to the country
were like, it was a quota.
It was only the most
highly educated Asians
who were allowed in,
who were Asians who were already
engineers, doctors and so forth.
In fact, I just wanna add,
like actually at least among Koreans,
the ones who were engineers
and doctors and so forth,
came in and they actually
ended more downwardly mobile.
They came in as doctors,
but they couldn't get the jobs,
because they were Asian immigrants.
So a lot of them ended up
like working at a deli,
or driving cabs and so forth.
So, I just wanna kind of add that.
So it's always served white Americans,
because we were used
as this kind of wedge.
Also I wanna say that,
it's very important to remember that
our status is conditional.
We have seen that with
Muslims, right after 9/11.
We're seeing that with those
who are East Asian, during COVID.
I use the example in the book
about my friend Prageeta Sharma,
whose father was president of,
was the first South
Asian president, I think,
for a small university.
Then once he became president,
he became a target of a lot of
these racist attacks,
because what I emphasize in the book is,
that once you actually gain power,
the model minority myth that helped you,
is turned against you.
Because being assimilated,
is not the same thing as having power.
He had power and so he
needed to be taken down.
Then Prageeta Sharma,
who was also a director
at a university program,
was just basically shat on
by her white colleagues.
I mean, it was just appalling,
but also not surprising.
However, I think there are also Asians,
of course, who benefit,
older Asian-Americans who,
I have my mother's friends,
some of my mother's friends
are voting for Trump,
because they don't want high taxes,
or because they think
their stocks are doing well
and who cares about the rest of America.
Then there are also, but for
me, like actually the most,
I hope that this book reaches out to
the Asian-Americans who
were like born here,
who are younger, who have
thrived and benefited
from Neo-liberal America,
those who work for Facebook
or Google, Goldman Sachs,
or who work as hedge funders,
many of who think they're
completely untouched
by the racial hierarchy and don't think
and equate a good neighborhood
with a white neighborhood.
I hope to reach out to them,
because I think they're the ones
who are actually adjacent to power.
Yeah, so it helps Asians too.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's such an interesting
and as you point out in the book and said,
Asians are probably the
highest income disparity
of any minority groups.
So in fact, there are so many
really poor Asians
and it must be so wrong,
- Exactly.
- To hear-
- well I mean,
that's where the model minority myth
is actually really quite damaging,
is that there is a huge disparity,
like where you have
Chinese, Hindu Indian
and Japanese Americans
who are a leap, who are on
the highest income bracket,
but then you have those
who are Southeast Asian,
who are on the lowest economic bracket.
So it's like the model minority myth,
of course, completely ignores and erases,
say the Hmong community in Minnesota,
who have really, really struggled,
or the Cambodians who are in California.
Yeah, it's a big issue.
- So, I'm sure many people have asked you
about this title, "Minor Feelings."
You describe minor
feelings in the book as,
I'm quoting, "The
racialized range of emotions
that are negative, dysphoric,
built from the sediments of
everyday racial experience
in the irritant of having
one's perception of reality,
constantly questioned or dismissed."
You cite scholars and
writers like Claudia Rankin
as inspirations in your
elaborations of the concept.
But I'm wondering what is
specifically Asian-American about,
or what is specifically
Asian about minor feelings?
Is there something, or does it
apply to all minority groups?
- I think it's like a
flexible kind of effect,
that I was also borrowing
from other theorists,
like Cyan Nye and Lauren
Berlin and so forth.
I do think that it can apply
to many marginalized groups where,
I mean, where they have
these minor feelings,
living in sort of a
capitalist, racist system
that promises social mobility,
without actually delivering it to you.
So when you feel stuck, you
think the onus is on you,
that it's your fault,
rather than thinking that it's structural.
But yes, I think it's
also very particular.
You could say it's also a
condition that I think is
and I have found after
the book was published,
that it really did speak to
a lot of Asian-Americans,
who read the book.
I was a little bit,
I was like, "Oh, I hope I'm
not speaking out of turn."
But I think what's
Asian-American about it is,
which may make it different than
which differentiates it from,
say other racial groups is,
this condition of being chronically
overlooked, dimunitized.
Asians, for instance,
are still not even named
when in the polls, when
their racial breakdowns
were still other,
'cause there's not enough of us,
or we're just like, too many
of us live in California.
So what's the point?
(laughs) You know?
But it's not just from the country.
I think for a lot of us, it
also comes from the home too,
where whatever your experiencing,
your perception of reality is
dimunitized, overlooked,
not just by America,
but from your family too,
because there's this real
kind of perhaps not all,
but for some that second generation,
first generation conflict
where parents probably have
more of a survivalist kind of survivor way
of looking at things,
versus the sense of alienation
that younger Asian-Americans have.
I think so there's this constant,
I felt that my rage or my melancholy,
or my questions weren't
worthy enough to address
and weren't worthy enough to make public
because of how I grew up,
because there weren't
representations of me in media,
but that's not the only reason.
I think it's even within the
rubric of racial politics,
I have heard a lot of Asians say,
like I had a younger student,
I had a student who said,
when there was a lot of
anti-Asian racism, during COVID,
she's like, "Oh, I just didn't
think it was right for me.
I mean I was talking to my black friend
and I didn't think it was right for me
to express my experiences of
xenophobia and inequality."
I think there's this kind of shame,
or sense of insufficiency,
where it's like,
where they think their oppression,
is not as extreme as Black
or indigenous people.
So there's this kind of
automatic internalized belittling,
or even self-gaslighting,
or trivializing of her own concerns.
This is why I wrote this book,
because I think it's really,
we can't play this game
of oppression Olympics.
In order to fight injustice,
you have to acknowledge and reckon with
and embrace your own life story
and what you had to go through,
in order to kind of have an allianceship
with other racial groups.
If you kind of deny yours,
or deny that kind of minor feelings
from other people like you,
then I don't think anything
can really be done.
I think it's very important.
I mean, I'm sorry, I'm
going on a little bit,
but I see some Asian-Americans who say,
like to call out other Asian-Americans as,
"You're being anti-Black.
Stop being so anti-Black."
I'm like, "I don't think
scolding is gonna work.
I think you need to first talk about
reconciling with what you went through,
that you have been taught
to deny and suppress
and open that up and only
through opening that up,
opening up your vulnerability,
will you really be able to fight
for a more equitable country."
- I think that's what Jia Tolentino,
I imagine she meant, that
you kind of pointed to,
you point throughout the book, I think,
to these feelings that,
people, not just Asians, I think.
I think this is really valid
for all minority groups,
but these sensations and
things that you've thought of,
but didn't know were a
thing kind of, you know?
I think by articulating that,
you just do a huge service to people.
So I wanna encourage people to
please send me questions in the Q and A.
I have a lot more questions,
so I'll keep going,
but please do send me your questions
and I'll start asking them in a minute.
But I wanted to pick
up on that question of
the relationship between
Asians and Blacks.
You have one of the most
painful sections of the book,
is your description of the
Rodney King Riots in LA,
in the early '90s and of the tensions,
especially between Koreans
and Korean-Americans
and Black people in that moment.
I'm wondering if you could just
say a little bit more about
where you see Asians fitting in
to the American racial system today
and especially at this moment,
of kind of renewed debate and questioning
of those hierarchies.
- Oh, it's very complex.
I think that there isn't enough discourse
between minorities about,
reconciling or just
addressing the anti-Blackness
within our communities.
Make no mistake, a lot
of Asians are anti-Black.
Now granted, this was more
older Asian-Americans.
I think, there's been a real C change,
which I find to be really
gratifying, actually,
I have to say.
Maybe this is just like the
people that I am exposed to,
but I will say just from experience,
Asian-Americans are,
at least like Millennials, Gen Z
and maybe some Gen X,
are much more galvanized,
much more activist, much
more aware and woke,
I guess, is the term,
to racial politics in this country
and really trying to fight the kind of
the colorism and the racism
within their communities.
I think we've gone far away.
We've come a far, far way, far,
since the LA Riots, when
there was this kind of
conflict between Koreans
and Black Americans.
Yet, we still have far to go.
I think the LA Riots,
a lot of people have
forgotten the LA Riots,
but I think it's still there.
I mean, the wounds have not healed.
I think like when a lot
of African-Americans
think about relations,
Black/Asian relations,
they bring up the LA Riots a lot
and about like how we were
hostile to the Black community.
It's a lot of work that we need to do,
but I think it's also
tricky for Asian-Americans,
because it's like, we're both,
as I said in the book,
we're in this purgatorial position where,
we're both oppressors in a
way, but we're also oppressed.
A lot of the ways in
which we are oppressed,
they're not seen ever, so.
- Again, I feel like
that's a real parallel
with the Jewish American experience,
especially historically.
Like early in the century,
many Jews were kind of forced,
because of prejudice,
into an economic niche,
where they were dealing
with minority groups
and it wasn't always rosy.
It's just complicated levels of racism,
that go into those relations.
So I think you really do
a great job in I think
honestly confronting that,
as a way to move beyond it.
So here's a question from,
we have a couple of
questions from the listeners.
So one is,
"If you could talk a little bit about
your research process, writing the book?"
This questioner was
really struck by the way
you were able to blend and contextualize
your own experiences,
both with history and
with writers before you.
So you, especially Asian
writers who you do a great job,
bringing attention to in the book.
- It was really like (laughs),
writing the book was,
I have to say, I was a little blindfolded,
because just kind of working on the book,
because I've never written non-fiction.
I mean, I've written reviews
and a couple essays, previously.
I guess I did have some
experience reporting,
but like I've never really written,
I'm a poet and I've never written
a book of nonfiction before.
So it was that.
Also, I wasn't really sure,
if any of the essays
were gonna come together.
So it was actually
really kind of terrifying
to write this book, 'cause it was all
really uncharted territory for me.
So it wasn't like I had this outline
of what the book was gonna be like.
I had these set of concerns
that I was gonna research.
What I did was, I just kind
of followed my obsessions.
I followed what I felt
compelled by, my compulsions.
I just hoped that my obsessions
would just kind of fall,
would just all kind of
neatly come together.
So I began, 'cause I wasn't thinking,
"I'm gonna write a book about
the Asian-American condition."
I did not think that.
It was originally gonna be a book,
when I conceived as a book of essays,
I was like, it was vaguer than that.
It was about race and institutional racism
and the arts, portrait of an artist,
my experience as a poet.
It was just sort of these
kind of vague ideas that I had.
With each chapter, it was a subject
that I just couldn't stop thinking about.
So we know with this book,
I began with the friendship essay,
which had maybe less research
and more to do with just kind of
really going back to that
time and remembering.
Then the Richard Pryor was also,
me researching standup comedy
and watching a lot of standup
and watching a lot of Richard Pryor,
which research that I had already done,
before working on this book,
because I was already
obsessed with Richard Pryor
and had all of this transcribed material,
during a period where I had writer's block
and I was like, "All right, I'm just gonna
transcribe Richard Pryor,
as if I was going to be
his apprentice or something."
I just didn't know what to do with it.
I had all of this sort
of research on comedy
and Richard Pryor and I was like,
"Maybe I could turn it
into poetry or something."
Instead, it just ended
up becoming this essay.
Then Theresa Hak Kyung Cha,
was another kind of obsession that I had.
I didn't actually want to work on that.
I didn't wanna do it, actually.
I was like, "This is too hard."
- Well, it's a very painful
episode in the book.
I mean, for those who haven't read it,
I don't know if you wanna just say?
- Yeah, it's an essay
about this poet/artist,
Theresa Hak Kyung Cha,
who was raped and
murdered in New York City,
in the early '80s.
I was really influenced
by her book, "Dictee",
when I was in college and have always been
influenced by her since then.
What I discovered was,
that no one has written
about her rape and murder.
So the book is, of the essay,
it's kind of like a true crime essay,
but it's also just more an investigation
about why the silence,
why no one wrote about it,
both among Asian-Americans and scholars
and also media at the time and so forth.
It was me kind of
digging into that silence
and also kind of giving myself
permission to write about it.
But I didn't wanna
write about it at first,
because I was like, "This is
too depressing of a subject."
I feel weird writing about it,
since like maybe the family
doesn't wanna talk about it
and it wasn't fun to write,
but I just felt compelled,
I had to write it.
So like I had these several essays
and then I just started realizing like
the kind of threads
started becoming visible.
It was like art making capitalism,
of course Asian-American
identity and so forth.
Then I started kind of shaping the essays,
so that they really had
more to do with that.
They kind of had more of a through line,
but I think when I was researching,
I was researching each
essay individually, yeah.
- I really feel like your feeling
when you called it a compulsion.
I think you can really
feel that in the book,
that these things you're
writing about them,
because you can't not write about them.
This actually relates to another question
from someone in the
audience, which is that,
"In the book you speak directly about
many sensitive topics like suicide,
but I would add also, rape and murder.
So how do you navigate the boundary
between processing and re-traumatization
and how you talk about certain incidents?"
I think the suicide, there's also,
I'm thinking of the friendship chapter
where you talk about your
two friends in college
and one of whom turns out to have
like pretty serious addiction
and mental health issues.
So anyway, if you could
say a little bit about
how you navigate that boundary.
- I think part of it is by being
as self-aware as possible and
as considerate as possible
and asking myself as many questions,
as I'm writing about it.
I think, I don't know if I'm interpreting
your term re-traumatization,
because I'm wondering,
is it re-traumatizing the reader?
- It's someone asking from the audience,
so I don't know exactly what she meant.
But I think what she means is,
by writing about this are you,
I don't know if she's
talking about re-traumatizing
in the person who might read it,
or anyone who has experienced
a similar thing who might get triggered
and therefore re-traumatized.
- Yeah, no, I mean, I think
that's a good question.
I mean, that was always on my mind.
Also, in the book I say, not only that,
I say, I also criticize
narratives of trauma.
Like who does this really benefit?
Is it really kind of,
is it gonna really also,
is it edifying or
empowering for the person,
for the group who had
this collective trauma,
or is this for the white audience?
I'm like, "Am I doing the same thing,
by writing about rape
and suicide and murder?"
But I think also,
and maybe this is an easy out,
but I also say, "Like,
I think writing about
any racial condition is gonna
be full of contradictions
and you just have to be open to it."
I think part of it was being very aware,
but I also had to push forward with it,
because like the case of
Theresa Hak Kyung Cha,
the reason why no one wrote about it was,
because of this fear of re-traumatization.
I also talk about this, right,
in the essay about Theresa Hak Kyung Cha,
where I say, at least
in certain communities,
the Asian-American community,
there is such a,
not to prioritize Western
thinking or something,
but in psychoanalysis,
the whole kind of basic tenant of
the talking cure is that
once you talk about it,
it no longer afflicts you, right?
It's no longer something that you feel
subconsciously oppressed by.
Whereas, within my family,
the kind of family I grew up in,
you couldn't talk about your pain,
because if you did, you not
only re-traumatized yourself,
but you re-traumatized
everyone around you.
You re-traumatized your mother,
your father and so forth.
Also, there was this
element of shame, right?
That by talking about,
let's say being sexually
assaulted or something,
then I was bringing
shame, by saying it aloud.
I really, really needed
to push against that,
because I think it's still,
that kind of culture is still very strong.
At the risk of re-traumatizing,
I think the fear of
re-traumatizing someone,
can also be very, very silencing
and can be even more
damaging than helpful, yeah.
- So another question from an
audience member about genre.
"So what genre do you
consider the book to be?
Because you've incorporated
the words of other artists,
your own personal life,
Asian-American history.
It's not a typical memoir autobiography."
I would just add to that,
what did your editor say?
So did your editor know
what you were gonna deliver
and did they try to push you to write
some more conventional autobiography?
No, okay so.
- No, I had it.
Well, actually, yes,
actually (laughs) yes.
I had a great editor.
I was fortunate to have an editor,
an Asian-American editor, Victory Matsui.
Victory's half Japanese,
gender non-binary.
They were really very tough, very good.
They didn't want me to
write anything conventional.
I was very fortunate.
No one did.
Not my agent, or my editor,
or the editor I had after Victory.
I think that I didn't really care
that it stuck to any kind of,
I didn't want to write a memoir.
I didn't wanna write a history book.
I didn't want to write a self-help book.
I wasn't thinking about that.
I wanted to, I think I just
instinctively interdisciplinary.
That's how I always was as a poet,
where I like was not interested in
just writing verse poetry.
I wanted to write prose poems
and I would play with science
fiction genres and stuff.
It was the same with nonfiction.
Like for me, it was more interesting
to write about my experience using
a variety of genres, 'cause I needed that.
I needed those different
systems of knowledge
to make my argument clear.
Victory was encouraging of that.
I would say in the
beginning, in earlier drafts,
the book was more, a
little bit more academic.
A little bit more
critical, more impersonal.
So actually, Victory
did push, pressure me,
I mean, encourage me, to be more personal
and more autobiographical.
I think it was more for sort
of the reader's experience,
but I'm glad that Victory did,
because I thought like by
making it more personal,
there was more at stake.
I think the book is
much more valuable to me
and I hope valuable to
readers, because of that,
yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I could see those traces of the academic.
You've read your critical
race theory and it shows,
but you're not just rehashing that.
I think that's really
important too.
- Yeah, I mean,
I had to write a book
that was very much me.
I mean and where I was coming from,
which is like, I come
from a poetry background.
I read critical race theory,
but not as a scholar.
It's not a scholarly book either.
I read history, I read randomly.
So it's gonna be a book that is
an assemblage of my random reading habits.
It's interesting, like
when this book ended up,
like in the summer, ended up on some
anti-racist reading list
and I was really glad
that people were reading
it alongside Ibram Kendi
and Ta-Nehisi Coates and all
those incredible writers.
But I was a little bit, I was like,
"This is a idiosyncratic book."
I think some people, some readers
had problems with that
who were expecting more of
a kind of broader kind of overview
on Asian-American history,
or kind of like a sort of,
or Robin DiAngelo's like,
"Self-help: What Do You Do?"
I'm like, "It was gonna
be a strange little book
and it still is."
A lot of it is just my
personal experiences
that clearly does not conform to
whatever the broad
Asian-American experience is, so.
- So here's a question.
I'm interested in how this book relates to
your day job as a poet and a
professor of creative writing.
So how have you negotiated
writing about racial issues in the past?
You talk about it in the book,
but maybe you can say something
and also what you don't really
say in the book is like,
has this changed your poetry now?
Like have you gone back and
started writing poetry again?
Is it any different for
having written this book?
- I haven't been writing that much poetry.
I guess when you go
pros, you don't go back.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
(laughing)
I think I have been writing some poems.
I think I, (sighs),
when I was writing poetry,
it wasn't autobiographical.
I wrote poetry like a fiction writer.
I had lots of different
characters and invented worlds.
It was a lot of world-building.
I think after writing "Minor
Feelings", it's opened me up.
I think I'm much more inclined to write
from an autobiographical perspective
and to be very transparent
about my thoughts and my life.
So I think that has definitely affected
what I've been writing so
far, which is both poetry,
some poetry and prose,
where I've been comfortable in the eye of,
"Minor Feelings" that
I've continued on with,
but I think I'm also more interested
in writing about other people's lives
and so I think in that way,
it's kind of a pivot to where,
it's less perhaps focused
on me and my ideas
about this country, my
perspective on this country
and what I'm reading and my personal life
and more pivot to other people's lives.
- So someone in the audience wants to know
if you would comment at all on
the college admissions lawsuits,
that Yale is now facing
and that are raised by questions
of Asian-American quotas
and things like that.
My understanding is that in fact,
most Asian groups on campus,
have been supportive
of affirmative action,
but I'm wondering if
you have any comment on
where that puts
Asian-Americans and the debate
within the Asian-American
community about that.
- What's the update?
I haven't been following.
- Asians are now bringing
a lawsuit against Yale now.
It seems to me with the new Supreme Court,
they're liable to throw
out affirmative action.
I don't know.
So it was defeated with Harvard,
but there's another one
that's coming up to Yale
and I'm sure they're gonna keep pushing.
- Oh, well I'm all for affirmative action.
I think that's horrifying that we would,
Asian-Americans would enable
the kind of federal overthrowing
of affirmative action.
I think we need to stop that.
That's not right.
I think, you know, it's hard.
Again, this is another kind
of a balancing act, right?
Because it's like, we
need affirmative action.
Asian-Americans have benefited
from affirmative action.
You cannot deny that.
I have benefited from affirmative action.
I mean, like I was like listening to
Young Jean Lee, this playwright,
wrote this op-ed for the New York Times.
She was saying, "I as a
playwright, I became successful."
I think she's doing herself a disservice.
She became successful,
'cause she's very talented,
but she's like,
"I became successful, because
of affirmative action.
There were no other
Asian-Americans around."
It's like and also we
came to this country,
because of the Civil Rights Movement,
because the Civil Rights Movement
was making America look bad
and look racist and xenophobic.
So that was part of the reason why
they opened their doors in 1965.
So we are part of that legacy.
For us to kind of, to undermine that
and to kind of just
overthrow affirmative action,
is just a betrayal.
I think it's a betrayal,
a real betrayal of what we're doing.
It's a prime example of
how we are used as a wedge,
first of all
and also how we-
- Asian-Americans
who are bringing the lawsuit,
it's just being done, in the name of,
so it's definitely they're being used,
in this sense.
- We're being used.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We're definitely,
and we are being used,
we're being used as a pawn.
Asian-Americans need
to fight against that,
really fight against this,
'cause I think, I've had enough.
We Asian-American have to say,
"Enough! We will not be used
as pawns for white supremacy."
I also am understanding of the fact
that there has been a
lot of discrimination
and that we are, that
Asian-Americans are not,
our subjectivities are not recognized,
by getting rid of affirmative
action, is not the answer.
I mean, of course what
needs to be addressed
is class more than anything
and what needs to be
addressed is the legacy,
legacy as affirmative action.
I don't know, I don't have the numbers,
but let's look at the racial
demographic of the legacy,
the people, the kids who are legacy.
Like Jared Kushner, being a
very good example of that.
- Right, or athletic recruits,
for sports like sailing.
Yeah, I have nothing
against people who sail,
but that is affirmative action
for rich people (laughs).
- Yeah, it is affirmative
action to rich people.
I just saw that one sort of graph where,
there was SAT scores were
proportional to family income.
So if your family income
was like $200,000 or more,
then you had the highest SAT scores
and then it just went down
from that and everything.
That's what
(banging)
needs to be addressed.
We are looking somewhere else.
By taking this to the Supreme Court,
is only enabling this racial hierarchy,
that we are already in.
- Yeah, so here's I think probably
our last question from the audience.
"So you write about in the book
being kind of opposed to writing about
Asian-American identity issues,
but of course, the whole
book is about that.
So what led you to
finally change your mind
about writing about
Asian-American identity?"
Which actually links up
with the last question
I had kind of wanted to ask you,
which is, have you changed your thoughts
on saying we in the book.
You write about, you have a hard time
talking collectively,
in a collective voice,
about Asian-Americans
and I'm wondering if that changed for you?
- I think it did.
I think I've been very
heartened by and really happy.
I thought I was afraid
about this book coming out.
I was afraid that no one would read it,
no one would care.
Because it's about Asian-American identity
and it's kind of a muted subject
and I don't think that,
but I think that's how
it's treated, approached.
I've been really, really heartened by,
the sheer number of readers
who have told me that they've felt seen
and that they recognize
themselves in the book.
It's not just East Asians.
It's a lot of East Asians,
it's also a lot of people
from other Asian-American demographic
and also non-Asian minorities too.
So I guess I feel more
emboldened to say we,
but I would still have
the caveat (laughs) there.
I think what's really
important to understand,
is that there are some,
there was this one
reviewer who was saying,
"But well, she doesn't really say",
was dissatisfied with the book,
because I don't really talk about
what the Asian-American experience is.
I just talk about sort of
our relations to white supremacy
and our fraught relationship
with African-Americans.
But they're like,
"But what about, what is
Asian-American experience?"
I'm like, "I can't answer that question."
Asian-American is a coalition
of different nationalities.
So what I'm trying to,
I guess why I wrote that book to say,
"Look, let's embrace the fact that
we are a coalition and
that as a coalition,
we need to kind of also
try to make bridges with
other people of color, or
people who are marginalized
and to build upon those coalitions,
to fight what this country has become now,
the fallen empire that is America."
I can't tell you what the
Asian-American experience is.
I can only tell you,
I mean, the book is my own perspective
on both the Asian-American experience
and also my perspective
as an Asian-American woman
on this country.
That was always the thesis of the book.
To answer the person's question,
I think it was, I always read about race
and it was something that
I was interested in for a long time,
to write a book about
Asian-American identity.
I think it was just because
I felt so uncomfortable about it.
I like to make my life hard by,
I'm like a moth to a flame.
I like to kind of write about
what I am scared of and what
I feel uncomfortable about,
because I'm like, "Oh well, what is there?
Why do I feel uncomfortable?"
But I've said this in many interviews,
It's also because I became a mother
and I was like,
"What kind of country do I
want my daughter to live in?"
I don't want her to have
the same kind of internalized racism,
that I had when I was a child.
I wanna protect her from that.
I want her to walk freely in this world.
So I wrote a book that I hoped was
a step towards that, in the world.
- Well, that's a great answer.
Unfortunately, we are out of time.
I feel like we could
go on talking all day.
Luckily, we know each other
and I can keep asking
you all the questions,
that I didn't get to ask you.
But for those of you who, unfortunately,
don't know you, I think that,
I just really advise
that you get a hold of
a copy as soon as possible
and read the book.
So Cathy, thank you so
much for talking to us.
This was a fantastic gift to
us and to the Yale community.
I'm really grateful.
So good luck with
everything and thank you.
- Thank you, this was a real pleasure.
Thank you, Mauri.
I hope we get to talk more later.
- [Maurice] Terrific, thank you.